الحصاد معكم جلال شهده في الوقت الذي
احدثكم فيه احداث تقع وتتفاعل اخرى
البدايه من عاصمه النيجر حيث خرجت مظاهرات
جديده داعمه للجيش تزامنا مع زياره وفد
وساطه لعلماء دين من نيجيريا الى طهران
وتوالي مزيد من المعلومات بشان هجوم مسلح
في مزار ديني بمدينه شيراز جنوبيه ايران
تبناه تنظيم الدوله
والى واشنطن وجديد متاعب ترامب القانونيه
تقارير عن ادله على اختراق فريق الرئيس
الامريكي السابق اجهزه اقتراع في ولايه
جورجيا بعد انتخابات 2020 الرئاسيه
في عناوين الحصاد
بعد محادثات في ميامي وفض وساطه من علماء
الدين المسلمين النيجيريين يقولون ان قاده
الانقلاب في النيجر منفتحون على الحل
الدبلوماسي برلمان مجموعه دول غرب افريقيا
يقرر ارسال لجنه الى النيجر وفي نيامي
مظاهره مؤيده للجيش ومندده بالتدخلات
الخارجيه
كيف تعلن مقتله مدنيين في قصف الروسي على
خيرسون جنوب اوكرانيا
هجمات بالمسيرات على
مقاطعتيتين ولاول مره منذ انسحاب موسكو من
اتفاق تصدير الحبوب الشهر الماضي سفينه
حربيه روسيه تطلق نيرانا تحذيريه على
سفينه شحن في البحر الاسود
واستم خوف من اتساع نطاق القتال في
السودان الاشتباكات تحتدم فينيالا بغرب
السودان ومناطق اخرى بولايه جنوب دارفور
حاكم اقليم دارفور يطالب طرفين نزاع في
السودان بوقف الحرب فورا وكاميرا الجزيره
ترصد الاوضاع الصحيه المتدهوره في ولايه
الجزيره
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا انهاء الازمه في النيجر
عبر وسائل دبلوماسيه في ضوء مهمه في نيام
لوفد وساطه من علماء الدين المسلمين
النيجيريين قال ان قاده الانقلاب منفتحون
على الحوار باستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا
الموضوع طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي في
رايكم في ضوء وساطه الوفد النيجيري ما هي
فرص انهاء ازمه النيجر بالوسائل
الدبلوماسيه الاجابه كانت على النحو
التالي 20% قالوا ان الفرص كبيره في حين
يعتقد نحو 36% ان الفرص محدوده اخيرا فضل
اربعه واربعون في المئه التصويت لصالح
القول انه لا فرص اطلاقا هذا السؤال سيبقى
مطروحا على منصاتنا الرقميه يمكنكم دخول
صفحه التصويت عبر مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر
على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا
تتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
هجوم استهدف مزار شاه جرى الديني في مدينه
الشيراز جنوبيه ايران
احتشد مؤيد المجلس العسكري في النيجر في
العاصمه نيامي لتعبير عن تاييدهم لموقف
المجلس والقرارات التي اتخذها وندد
المتظاهرون بمواقف بلدان غرب افريقيا التي
فرضت عقوبات على المجلس ورفعوا شعارات
تطالب المجلس العسكري بمواصله التعاون مع
مالي وبوركينا فاسو
للمجلس العسكري وللقرارات التي
اتخذها بعض قاده الجيش بالاطاحه بالرئيس
محمد وبازوم وايضا
للتنديد
بمواقف بلدان مجموعه غرب افريقيا التي
فرضت عقوبات على المجلس العسكري في الناجا
متواجدون هنا شعارات تطالب ايضا بمواصله
المجلس العسكري تعاونه مع مالي ومع
بوركينا فاسو كما يرفعون الاعلام الروسيه
وهي للمطالبه بان يحدو المجلس العسكري
حذوا مالي وبوركينا فاسو في توسيعه تعاونه
مع روسيا حتى تتمكن النيجر ايضا من محاربه
الجماعات المسلحه وفي نفس الوقت ايضا
يطرحون روسيا كبديل للتعاون مع فرنسا
المستعمر السابق للنادر والتي يقولون انها
سبب السبب الاساسي
لتدهور الوضع الامني في النيجر
فضل عبد الرزاق الجزيره
الدكتور علي تاسع الاكاديمي والدبلوماسي
السابق دكتور القاده الافارقه والغربيون
يطالبون بما يسمونها عوده الحياه
الديمقراطيه للنيجر ما هي صيغه قاده
الانقلاب لانفتاحهم على الحوار كما يقولون
اهلا بك وبالمشاهدين لو كانت لهجه قناه
الدول الافريقيه او قالت الدول المجموعه
لو كانت هذه هي لهجه من البدايه لست معي
اليهم الجيش لان الجيش لم يرفض الحوار فقط
رفض ان يملا عليه ما يفعل ففي البدايه
مجموعه الاقوس فردت على النيجر عقوبات
واغلقت الحدود ثم ارسلت محاورين
رفض قال على اي اساس
يفاوض اما الان فهو مستعد للتفاوض معنى
ذلك انه مستعد
للمفاوضه حول الفتره الانتقاليه التي
سيحددها مع التشاوري مع قناه مجموعه الدول
الاقوى ولكن في المقابل دكتور
قاده الانقلاب رفضوا استقبال مفردين من
ايكواس هم ماضون في تشكيل حكومه شكلوا
حكومه استاثروا بالحقائب السياديه من
رسائل التي يرسلها قاده الانقلاب
لقاده دول افريقيا خاصه
كما ذكرت في مستحيل لك لاحاديثي هو ان
مجموعه الدول
الاكواس في البدايه يعني شددت في كلامها
في حديثها حول
القاده الانقلابيين
فقالت لابد من اعاده السلطه الى محمد بازم
لا بد من الافراج عنه واعادته الى السلطه
يعني الشخص الذي
سل صفه امامك ثم يقول لك تعال نتحاور كيف
تستمع اليه لذلك رفضوا ان يقابلوا الفوج
الاول الذي ارسله رئيس نيجيريا تحت قياده
الرئيس الاسبق عبد السلام ابو بكر وبرفقته
امير السكوتو رفض ان يقابلهم ايضا الذي
كان كان يتشكل من مجموعه الايكوس ومجموعه
ماذا يسمى الافريقيه وكذلك
الامم المتحده رفض ان يقابله لكن لما جاء
امير كانوا الاسبق قال جاء بصفته الشخصيه
جاء ليفوض ولما جاء العلماء جاءوا
ليفاوضوا قبلهم الجيش وقبلهم لان حده
الكلام يعني انخفضت في نيجيريا انتم
الوقت الديني النيجيري قال بان قاده
الانقلاب اكثر انفتاحا على الحوار ما هي
صيغتهم لعوده الحياه الديمقراطيه في في
النيجر
قناه الانقلاب مستعدون على ان تكون هناك
فتره
انتقاليه للحكم العسكري
ومستعدون ان يفوضوا مع قاده دول الغربي
افريقيا حول المده هل تكون سنه هل تكون
اقل من سنه هل تكون اكثر من سنه هم
منفتحون على هذه الحوار ما في اي مانع لكن
ان يملا عليهم
الاء انهم لابد ان يرجعوا الرئيس السابق
فهذا الذي لم يسوغوه ولن يقبلوه لا اعتقد
سريعا اجابه سريعه لو سمحت في اي اطار
ياتي طلب قاده الانقلاب الدعم الغينيا
باقتراب لو سمحت
لا هو اصلا هذا الدعم كان طلبه
الانقلابيون من مالي وطلبوهم من بوركينا
لان النفس وزير
وزير الدفاع قبل حتى ان يعين وزير الدفاع
كان سافر الى مالي سافر الى بوركينا
وحاليا سافر الى غينيا للتضامن لانه يعرف
انه اذا قالت هذه الدول بانها ستهاجمه
النيجر فهذه الدول يمكن ان تكون سندا
للنيجر شكرا في مواجهه دولي مجموعه
المجموعه الاقتصاديه لغرب افريقيا شكرا لك
الدكتور علي تاسع في نيمه
وكما اسلفنا كان وفد وساطه من علماء
نيجيريا قد قال انه اتفق مع قاده الانقلاب
في النيجر على تكثيف الحوار لحل الازمه
على صعيد متصلا قال مراسل الجزيره ان
الجلسه الطارئه لبرلمان مجموعه اكواس شهدت
انقساما حادا بين اعضائها حاله دون
التوافق على قرار موحد بشان التدخل
العسكري بالنيجر من جهه اخرى يتوقعوا ان
يعقد مجلس السلم والامن الافريقي غدا
الاثنين اجتماعه الذي كان مقررا امس السبت
وارجئ لاجراء مزيد من التشاور بين الاعضاء
بشان تعليق محتمل لعضويه النيجر
لا حل هنا من دونهم الان على الاقل بينما
الدبلوماسيه تعمل
ليس من مد الاذن من التواصل مع قاده
الانقلاب في النيجر
تراهم يستقبلون وفودا ويردون اخرى وشاهدوا
انهم تعاملوا بايجابيه مع مهمه وفد وساطه
من علماء نيجيريا
هذا اللقاء مهم الهدف منه هو التقريب بين
البلدين نيجيريا لقد حملوا رساله رئيس
نيجيريا الى رئيس الدوله هنا والرئيس
حملهم مهمه شرح كل ما نريد ان نراه في
الايام القادمه بمعنى رفع الاجراءات غير
الانسانيه وغير المسبوقه واللام مقبوله
لان هذه الاجراءات تتعارض حتى مع ترتيبات
اكواس لكننا نبقى مرحبين بهذه الوساطه
التي ستقودنا الى رفع هذه القيود والعوده
الى الاوضاع الطبيعيه
كل يرى الطبيعيه من الامور من زاويته اما
المؤسسات الرسميه الافريقيه فلا تزال
النيجر تلتقط اشاراتها على ترددات مختلفه
يتاهب قاده جيوش المجموعه الاقتصاديه لدول
غربي افريقيا اكواس الاجتماع يبحث خطط
التدخل العسكريه في النيجر وقبلها تم
تفعيل القوات الاحتياطيه للمجموعه كما
اوصت بذلك قمه ابوجا الاخيره لكن في الوقت
عينه يقرر برلمان ويكوس ارسال لجنه الى
نياميه لمقابله قاده الانقلاب وبحث سبل
انهاء الازمه دبلوماسيا
ما زال البرلمان يتجاذبه موقفا احدهما
متمسك بالسبل الدبلوماسيه حسره والاخر يرى
ضروره اتخاذ موقف حازم يرضع كل طامح الى
احداث تغيير الغير دستوري في المنطقه
من مؤسسات العمل الافريقيه المشترك من
يكتفي في هذه المرحله بالرسائل لكن حتى
هذه تحتاج لمزيد من المشاورات ذا كما
يفعله مجلس السلم والامن الافريقي بشان
قرار محتمل بتعليق عضويه النيجر يبدو ان
شيئا من ذلك يشغل المنقلبين هناك على سلطه
الرئيس محمد بازوم عن تنفيذ اجندتهم
نصبوا حكومه جديده نصف اعضائها من
العسكريين استاثروا بالحقائب السياديه
انهم يدفعون بالمرحله الانتقاليه قدما على
امل ارغام المجتمع الدولي على التطبيع مع
حاله النيجر
المجلس العسكري ايضا يطلق في سبيل ذلك
رسائل عن التماسك الداخلي للجيش والاجهزه
الاخرى ورسائل غيرها عن احتضان الشعب
للفعل الانقلابي من خلال مظاهرات مسانده
تخرج او تخرج كل حين كما يعتد قاده
الانقلاب بوقوف اصحاب مشاريع مشابهه في كل
من مالي وبوركينا فاسو ضد التدخل العسكري
في النيجر فهل اطمئنت جماعه الى ان حل
عسكريا لوضع النيجر المستجد
لعلهم يدركون ان اكواس لم يسبق انشنت
هجوما في دوله عضو الا بموافقه منها لكنهم
يدركون حتما ان اي شيء ممكن هنا فهذه
افريقيا
لصباح تحركات الافريقيه ينضم الينا من
اديس ابابا الدكتور سلمون ديرسو الخبير في
الشؤون الافريقيه دكتور امام تراجع الخيار
العسكري ما هي الخيارات السياسيه
الدبلوماسيه المطروحه امام ايكواس
والاتحاد الافريقي
المبادره الدبلوماسيه والسياسيه
هناك عدد منها فكما تتذكرون ان الرئيس
لاكواس رئيس نيجيريا رئيس
كان قد بعث بوفد توجه الى نعمه في السادس
من اغسطس
وحيث التقوا بالرئيس
برئاسه الرئيس السابق للنيجيريا مع الاسف
لم يحضروا فرصه اللقاء
برئيسه وقائد الانقلاب وبعد ذلك كان هناك
بعث الدبلوماسيه اخرى بمبادره
من الحاكم نيجيريا السابق الخلوصي الذي
استطاع ان يلتقي
بقائد الانقلاب واليوم ايضا وصلنا تقرير
من العلماء المسلمين من نيجيريا الذين
التقوا بقائد الانقلاب وتوصلوا الى
تفاهمات
وعبروا عن الاستعداد عن اجراء الحوار او
التواصل الدبلوماسي مع اكواس
كما انه كان هناك اتحاد الاوروبي والاتحاد
الاوروبي بعث بوفدين
لم يصنعوا السفر الى نعمه في الثامن اغسطس
واضح دكتور ما الاشارات التي تصل لمجموعه
اكواس والاتحاد الافريقي من قاده الانقلاب
وعدم مبالاتهم بالمهل والتحذيرات التي
يطلقونها تجاهها انهاء الانقلاب في النيجر
والصوفه لحد الان
ومن المؤشرات التي يخصها من
اتصالات اليوم ان قاده
الانقلاب عبروا انهم مستعدون للتواصل
الدبلوماسي مع الكواز
وان القمه الاستثنائيه لاكوا سكان للعاشره
من
اغسطس اب قبل بضعه ايام
تراجعت عن خيار
التدخل العسكري وكما عززوا عززت العقوبات
وفي الوقت ذاته فان القلابيين ايضا
يعتبروا تهديدات
كخدعه او تهديد
واجتماعات مع علماء المسلمين اليوم كان
هناك فعلا اتفاق على
القثه
الطريق الدبلوماسي بين النيجر
ومن هذه الثورات لحد الان يبدو ان الامور
تبشر بخير مشى السلم والامن سياخذ اجتماعا
في الساعات المقبله ما الذي يمكن ان يضيفه
من قرارات في سبيل عوده الحياه
الدبلوماسيه والديمقراطيه او الديمقراطيه
عفوا والمؤسساتيه في النيجر كما يطالب
قاده افريقيا
فيما يتعلق
عمليه ديمقراطيه فهذا ليس بالشيء الذي
يمكن تحقيقه بسهوله
جزء من المشكله هو ان هناك عده
انقسامات واراء حول ما يسمى
بالتوقف الديمقراطي في البلاد اما فيما
يتعلق باجتماعات غدا مع الاتحاد الافريقي
اعتقد ان اهم توقع سوى ان الاتحاد
الافريقي سيساعد اقوى
النيجر
للابتعاد عن طريق المواجهه العسكريه
اذ ان مثل هذه النتيجه ستكون كارثيه ليس
فقط للنيجر انما ايضا لكل منطقه الاكواس
بسبب
السياق السياسي والامني الذي تجد فيه
نفسها الاكواس وخاصه النيجر
بنظر نظرا لان النينجا هي جزء من منطقه
الساحل
المتاثره
للمجموعات الارهابيه وان قتال بين اكوا سن
نيجر سياتي
سيؤثر على الجهود كل ما الاكواس والنجر
لاحتواء انتشار الارهاب في المنطقه
وبالتالي هناك حاجه ماسه جدا
شكرا ان يحاول ان يخفي التوازن على جهود
تجنب اي تراجع في مكافحه الارهاب في منطقه
الساحل ايضا الابقاء على مبدا صفر من
التسامح
والقبول للعمل العسكري نتوقع ان مجلس
الامن والسلام سيقرر تعليق شكرا
الدكتور سلمان في الشؤون الافريقيه شكرا
لك
اتابعه بملف حربي روسيا على اوكرانيا حيث
قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان انظمه
الدفاع الجوي اسقطت مسيره اوكرانيه فوق
منطقه كورسك كانت متجهه لضرب اهداف على
الاراضي الروسيه واوضحت ان اسقاط المسيره
لم يسفر عن اصابات او خسائر ماديه كما
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه اسقاط ثلاث
مسيرات فوق اراضي منطقه قالت انها حاولت
تنفيذه هجوم على اهداف داخل روسيا
كما افادت وسائل اعلام روسيه بان حريقا
ضخما اندلعا في مستودع للاسمده بمنطقه
رامين سكوي في ضواحي العاصمه موسكو وذكرت
وكاله توريه نوفوستي ان المستودع يمتد على
مساحه 1000
مربع وقد اظهرت الصور المتداوله سحبا
كثيفه من الدخان الاسود تتصاعد من موقع
الحريق
وقد اعلنت وكاله الانباء الاوكرانيه مقتل
سبعه اشخاص في قصف روسي على قريتين في
مقاطعه خيرسون كما اعلنت هيئه الاركان
الاوكرانيه مقتل واصابه عدد من المدنيين
اثر استهداف القوات الروسيه مناطق في
اوكرانيا بصواريخ مجنحه وقصف جوي ومدفعي
واكدت الهيئه ان قواتها صدت هجمات روسيه
في اتجاهات كوبيانسك بمقاطعه
بمقاطعه دونيسك كما وصلت هجماتها في
مقاطعه
وقالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه انها نفذت
عمليه انزال وتفتيش لسفينه كانت متجهه
لميناء اسماعيل الاوكراني واضافت ان
السفينه تابعه تابعت عفوا ابحارها بعد
انتهاء التفتيش وقد وصف مستشار رئاسه
الاوكرانيه عمليه الانزال بانها انتهاك
للقانون الدولي للبحار وجريمه قرصنه ضد
سفن مدنيه لدوله ثالثه في مياه دول اخرى
تفاصيل التوتر المتصاعد في الممرات
البحريه المخصصه لتصدير الحبوب الاوكرانيه
في التقرير التالي
اوكرانيا تحاول استعاده ممرات سفن شحن
الحبوب وفق اتفاق البحر الاسود لكن دون
ذلك معوقات فروسيه التي انسحبت من
الاتفاقيه لوحت مرارا باستهداف السفن التي
قد تشكل خطرا عسكريا عليها وهذا
السيناريوباه واقعا وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
اكدت ان قواتها نفذت عمليه انزال على
سفينه شحن كانت في طريقها لميناء اسماعيل
الاوكراني وبحسب الاعلان الروسي فان سفينه
الشحن لم تستجب لطلب القوات الروسيه
بالتوقف بتفتيشها فنفذت عمليه انزال على
متنها لتتابع مسارها بعد اتمام عمليه
التفتيش الاعلان تزامن مع تعزيز روسيا من
قطاعها البحريه في البحر الاسود بحسب
الجانب الاوكراني
المتحدثه باسم قياده عمليات الجنوب في
الجيش الاوكراني تحدثت عن ان مجموعه السفن
العسكريه الروسيه في البحر الاسود تقدر
بنحو 15 سفينه تنتشر بشكل متفرق وان
القوات الروسيه شكلت ما وصفته اوكرانيا
بمنطقه تفتيش للسفن قرب مضيق كوتش هذه
التطورات تاتي ضمن سياق عسكري روسيا
استهدفت في الاسابيع الاخيره اهم موانئ
اوكرانيا على البحر الاسود من اودي
الساستراتيجي واستهدفت ايضا الموانئ
البديله على نهر الدانوب من اريني وميناء
اسماعيل اوكرانيا بدورها نفذت هجمات على
ميناء نوفروسيسك الذي يعد اكبر موانئ
روسيا حيث استهدفت سفينه انزال واختلفت
الروايات عن حجم الضرر التي لحق بها كما
حددت اوكرانيا عددا من الموانئ الروسيه
وقالت انها س اهدافا مشروعه لقوتها لتبقى
مدينه سيباس عرضه لهجمات اوكرانيه متكرره
بطائرات مسيره في اطار ما يراه خبراء
تغييرا في استراتيجيه اوكرانيا في هجومها
المضاد باعتماد ضربات تستهدف منشات
استراتيجيه وحيويه وتخترق العمق الروسيه
وتصل للعاصمه موسكو بدلا من الهجوم البري
الواسع وفي هذا الاطار نشرت هيئه الاركان
العامه للقوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه صورا
قالت انها تظهر تدريب القوات الخاصه
البريطانيه قرابه الف جندي من مشاه
البحريه الاوكرانيه على القيام بعمليات
برمائيه على متن قوارب صغيره
العميد الياس حنا الخبير العسكري واستراتي
الينا من بيروت العميد حنا ماذا تقرا
بزياده وتيره المسيرات الاوكرانيه باتجاه
الاراضي الروسيه
جلال اولا هي مرحله جديده او ديناميكيه
جديده بسبب التعثر في الهجوم الاوكراني
منذ شهرين فاذا انت امام مسيرات قصيره
المدى بعيده المدى تصل الى
العمق الروسي حتى موسكو وتصل الى جسر قرش
منها البريه ومنها البحريه ومنها الجويه
وهذا امر مهم جدا هذا يدل ان لدى اوكرانيا
استراتيجيه جديده او مقاربه جديده وهذا
ايضا يدل ان لدى اوكرانيا القدره على
تصنيع هذه المسيرات خاصه البحريه وهي من
صنع محلي زياده التركيز الاوكراني والضغط
على جزيره القرم الى ماذا يؤشر
جزيره القرم جلال هي
الممر الاساسي عبر جسر كرش وجسر شمبار
المنطقه الاساسيه هي التي توزع هذه
الشرايين اللوجستيه التي توزع الى الجنوب
الاوكراني ان كان باتجاه خرسون او زفروجيا
كل اللوجستيه لجيش يعتمد على ذخيره
ويستهلك ذخيره بشكل كبير القضيه اليوميه
او الهدف دائما هو حرمان الجيش الروسي
الذي يقاتل في الجنوب من اللوجستيه
وبالتالي ما يسمى بالدينايل او المنع او
الانكار وبالتالي العمل على الخرق ان كان
في الوسط اذا بيولوجيا او حتى في
بخموت التوترات في البحر الاسود عميد حنا
الى اين ممكن ان تؤدي وما مؤشراتها في هذه
المرحله
هذه المرحله السفينه التي تحدثت عنها جلال
هي السفينه التي تعتبر حسب اوكرانيا انها
الكوريدور الجديد الذي ياتي من
او القمح او التصدير الذي ياتي من اوديسا
برا او عبر السكك الحديد الى
مرفع اسماعيل وبالتالي عبر العوامات او
البوارج البحريه باتجاه رومانيا ومن ثم
الذهاب الى الممرات التركيه هذا الامر
تعتبره روسيه يناقض ما قررت ان تقوم به
الشيء الجديد انها صعدت الى السفينه اطلاق
انذار تحذيري ولم تدمر السفينه كما وعدت
في المرات السابقه
هذه الديناميه الجديده التي او الاسترجيه
الجديده التي شرحتها الى اي مدى تزعج
وتؤرق الجيش الروسي في المرحله عم يتحنى
في في البحر الاسود جلال شيء مهم جدا هذه
المسيرات البحريه وحتى الجويه وبكلفه
قليله اعاد الترتيب موازين القوى يعني انت
لديك بارجه بملايين مئات ملايين الدولارات
مقابل
مسيره لا تزيد لا يزيد سعرها عن 250 الف
دولار ومن صنع المحلي يعني انت فرطت قواعد
اشتباك جديده بين قوه بسيطه اوكرانيا وقوه
عظمى مثل روسيا واعت رسم موازين القوى
بشكل ان يفكر الروسي في اي وقت يحرك
ويتدخل لهذه القطعه البحريه العميد الياس
حنا في بيروت شكرا لك
قال مصدر عسكري بالجيشه السوداني للجزيره
ان قوات الجيش صدت هجوما لقوات الدعم
السريع على مقر الفرقه السادسه عشره في
مدينه نيالا الغربيه السودان واشار المصدر
الى ان الجيش تمكن من تدمير عربتين
قتاليتين وكبد المهاجمين خسائر بشريه
وبحسب مصادر محليه فن الاشتباكات بين
الطرفين تعتبر الاعنف منذ مده وقد دارت
داخل احياء المدينه وتسببت في نزوح عشرات
الاسر
جاته طلب حاكم اقليم دارفور مني اركو من
ناوي طرفي نزاع في السودان بوقف الحرب
فورا والدخول في حوار سياسي وقال ان الحل
السياسي يجب ان يترك للشعب السوداني
ندعو طرفين بوقف الحرب فورا واي حرب لازم
تنتهي بالحوار والتفاوت ولذلك يجب ان يبدا
التفاوت ولكن الحل السياسي يجب ان يترك
لشعب السوداني يجب ان يترك لسعب شعب
السوداني الاربعين مليون مش الشعب
السوداني 40 شخص اللي اشعله الحرب
قالت مصادر محليه بجنوب كردفان للجزيره ان
معارك عنيفه دارت بين الجيش السوداني وقوه
الحركه الشعبيه شمال بقياده عبد العزيز
الحلو في منطقه دلامي جنوب شرقي الدلنج
منذ مساء امس حتى صباح اليوم جاءتي اقاله
مراسل الجزيره ان اصواتها اطلاق نار كثيف
سمعت في وسط وشرقي اندرمان مع تصاعد اعمده
دخان وقالت مصادر محليه من الجيش السوداني
قصف بالمدافع مواقع لقوات الدعم في ضحيه
ام بدر غربيه ام درمان كما قالت مصادر
عسكريه بالجيش السوداني للجزيره ان
الطائرات المسيره التابعه للجيش استهدفت
ايضا تجمعات للدعم السريع في الاحياء
القريبه من سلاح المدرعات بالعاصمه
في تداعيات الانسانيه قال وزير الصحه
بولايه الجزيره وسط السودان اسامه عبد
الرحمن ان الاوضاع الصحيه في ولايته صعبه
للغايه بسبب الاعداد الكبيره للمرضى
الوافدين من الخرطوم
لا تملك بخيته سوى الامل بشفاء ابنها
المصاب بسرطان منذ نحو سبعه اعوام جاءت به
الى ود مدني قبل اربعين يوما لقد انهك
الالم جسده النحيل
ثاني حاليا احنا جايين من خمسه ولايات لحد
مدني
علاجات ما متوفره
ومعاناه شديده يعني
يقدم هذا المستشفى خدماته لمرضى السرطان
لكن جرعات العلاج الكيميائي غير متوفره
وجهاز العلاج الاشعاعي معطر بشكل كامل
وصل الاف المرضى الى ولايه الجزيره
المتاخمه بينهم كثيرون مصابون بالفشل
الكلوي ضاعف العاملون في المستشفى ساعات
عملهم لكن النقص الحاد في المعدات الطبيه
والادويه يهدد بتوقف الخدمه
مئات الالاف المرضى استقبلتهم المراكز
الصحيه بالولايه منذ اندلاع الحرب حسب
وزاره الصحه في ظروف صعبه يعني كانت
الخاصه والمورده واصحاب التوكيلات من
الشركات الدوليه هي كلها كانت متمركزه في
الخرطوم يعني
ومخازنا ومناطق عملياتها الامداد بتاعها
اللي كان بيجي لولايه الجزيره هو كله تاثر
يعني بشكل كبير جدا يعني بيبقى الاشكاليات
الماليه والاشكاليات اللوجستيه ومخازن
الدواء والتوكيلات الطبيه حتى ان هي تاخذ
وضع الطبيعي فبالتالي نحن سنعاني والمواطن
سيعاني
في اكبر مستشفى لامراض القلب بمدينه
ودمدني اجريت اكثر من 700 عمليه قسطره
تشخيصيه وعلاجيه خلال اربعه اشهر مع نقص
في معدات مثل جهاز تنظيم ضربات القلب
يستمر توافد الكثيف للمرضى من العاصمه
واحده ولايات الى مستشفيات ولايه الجزيره
ما احدث ضغطا هائلا على الخدمات المقدمه
من هذه المستشفيات التي باتت تعاني هي
ايضا شحا في الدواء والمستلزمات الطبيه
الاخرى اسامه سيدي احمد الجزيره من مدينه
الجزيره وسط السودان
سنعود الى التطورات في السودان لاحقا في
فقره المتابعه لنسلط الضوء على اقليم
دارفور وخصوصيته ونسال خبيرا عسكريا
سودانيا عن مخاطر اتساع الاضطرابات
الامنيه في الاقليم
اعلن التلفزيون الايراني مقتل شخص واصابه
ثمانيه بجروح في هجوم
في مدينه شيراز جنوبيا البلاد واضاف
التلفزيون ان تنظيم الدوله تبنى المسؤوليه
عن الهجوم فيما قال الحرس الثوري في مدينه
شيراز ان القوات الامنيه القت القبض على
احد المهاجمين وان البحث مستمر عن المهاجم
الثاني وذكرت وسائل اعلام ايرانيه ان
المهاجمين اجنبيين وفي حين وصف الرئيس
الايراني الهجوم بالجريمه الارهابيه قال
وزير الخارجيه ان بانتظار المسؤولين عنه
وداعميهم عقابا قاسيا
من طهران عمر هواش عمر اخر التطورات فيما
يتعلق بشقين الميداني والسياسي
نعم ميدانيا تبدا او بدات وسائل الاعلام
الايرانيه بنشر صور منفذ الهجوم بعد
اعتقاله اضافه الى صوره الضحيه الوحيده
القتيل الوحيد في هذا الهجوم في التفاصيل
جلال عند السابعه مساء في ساعه الذروه في
المزار الديني الواقع في مدينه شيراز
جنوبيه البلاد حيث كانت تقترب صلاه المغرب
هاجم احد هو منفذ وحيد هجم المزار اطلق
النيران عشوائيا اولا باتجاه غرفه حراس
هذا المزار ثم اتجه نحو الداخل واطلق
النار عشوائيا بالاجمال ادى هذا الهجوم
الى قتيل واحد وثمانيه جرحى يقال ان اثنين
منهم في حاله حرجه يخضعون لعمليه جراحيه
في احد المشافي في المدينه هذا الهجوم ادى
فقط الى قتيل واحد واذا قار الهجوم الذي
جرى في نفس المكان وربما بنفس الطريقه في
اكتوبر الماضي في اكتوبر الماضي ادى ذلك
الهجوم الى 13 قتيلا بينما اليوم هذا
العدد هو اقل تتحدث وسائل الاعلام
الايرانيه عن ان منذ ذلك التوقيت كان هناك
دوريات متتابعه ضمن
الشفتات
ورديات متلاحقه لحراسه هذا المكان
وبالتالي قوات الامن تمكنت من تقديم اداء
افضل مقارنه مع الهجوم السابق ردود الفعل
داخل ايران توالت عبر الرئيس الايراني
اولا الذي اجرى اتصال بوزير الداخليه
وبمحافظ مدينه شيراز اكد على ضروره
الاسراع في الكشف عن ملابسات هذا الحادث
وملحقه منفذي هجومهم والهجوم ومن يقفون
ورائهم كذلك اصدر بعد ذلك بيان طلب في
وزاره الاستخبارات القوات الامنيه السلطه
القضائيه القوات الشرطه ايضا بملاحقه
اعتقال اي مسؤول اخر عن الهجوم ربما قدم
اي مساعدات او ماوى للمنفذ الذي تم
الاعتقاله هو بدا استجوابه اكد ان مرتكبي
هذا الهجوم سوف يتلقون عقابا قاسيا نفس
الامر قال هو وزير الخارجيه الايراني حسين
امير عبد الليان في تغريده على موقع اكس
قال ان هذا الهجوم هو هجوم ارهابي مودان
بشده وان منفذيه ومن يقفون وراءهم سوف
يتلقون عقابا قاسيا عندما تتحدث طهران عن
من يقف وراء اي هجمات توصف هنا بالارابيه
هي تقصد دائما ما تصفه بالقوى الاستكباريه
وبالتحديد تقصد الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه واسرائيل بنفس الدرجه شكرا لك
يا عمر في طهران
افادت شبكه سي ان ان نقلا عن مصادر بان
المدعين العامين في ولايه جورجيا يمتلكون
وثائق تظهر تلاعب فريق ترامب بنتائج
انتخابات عام 2020
مزيد من الملاحقات القضائيه تحاصر دونالد
ترامب من ولايه جورجيا هذه المره ينتظر
الرئيس الامريكي السابق اتهامات جديده
تتعلق بشبهات حول تدخل فريقه لتعطيل مسار
انتخابات 2020
الجوله الجديده من المحاكمات كانت منتظره
سلفا في شهر اغسطس الحالي ويبدو انها اخذه
في الاقتراب بعد ان ارسلت المدعيه فاني
ويليس مذكرات لشهود في القضيه طالبه منهم
الاستعداد للادلاء بشهاداتهم قبل نهايه
الشهر الجاري كما نقلت وسائل اعلام
امريكيه قبل ايام يتركز الحديث على
ملابسات جرت في ولايه جورجيا وتحديدا
بمقاطعتك فيه حيث فاز ترامب بنحو 70% نسبت
شبكه سي ان ان لمصادر مطلعه على التحقيقات
ان ثمه وثائق تثبت اختراق فريق ترامب
انظمه التصويت بمقاطعه كافي بقصد التلاعب
من نتائج انتخابات 2020
لم يكن اختراقا تطوعيا من فريق الرئيس
السابق كما يرى ممثلي الادعاء بل بتنسيق
مباشر مع مقربين من ترامب لدى المحققين
وفق سي ان ان رسائل الكترونيه ونصيه
تبادلتها ميستي هامبتون وهي مسؤوله
انتخابيه جمهوريه في المقاطعه مع اعضاء
مباشرين في فريق ترامب من بينهم محامياه
رودي جولياني وسيدني باول استاجر محاموت
ترامب وفق مصادر سي ان ان شركه لفحص انظمه
التصويت تدعى
سهلت وصولا غير مشروع الى انظمه التصويت
بمقاطعتك فيه من بين الوثائق تسجيلات
المصوره لوجود مسؤول انتخابي جمهوري
واعضاء من الشركه في منطقه محظوره من مكتب
الانتخابات بالمقاطعه يذكر ان مسؤولا
سابقا في اداره ترامب كان قد شهد بوقوع
نقاش لخطط الوصول لانظمه التصويت في
جورجيا خلال اجتماع انضمت ترامب نفسه قبيل
نهايه عام 2020
وصلت سلطات جورجيا التحقيق منذ عام 2021
واستمعت المدعيه الى شهاده 75 شخصا بينما
رفض احد القضاه طلبا تقدم به ترامب
لاستبعادها
مساعد نائب وزير العدل الامريكي سابقا
والخبير القانوني المستشار فاين مقارنه
بتهم السابقه التي وجهت وجهت للرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب ما جديه وقوه هذه
التهمه الان
في
الاتهام القادم من
جورجيا يتماشى ويتطابق مع الاحداث التي
ادت الى ما حدث في يناير
2006 ومحاولات
تزييف
النتائج والتصويت لها علاقه بالجهود يا
سيد ترامب
للضغط على
امين سر الولايه ليعثر له على احد عشر الف
صوت ليعدل النتيجه وهناك مزاعم بان هناك
الكثير من المتعامرين مع الجيب فريق
الرئيس
لكي يغيروا النتيجه
ومع الحاكم الجمهود الولايه ومع امين سر
الجمهوري رغم ان رغم الجهود اثبتت عدم
وجود تلاعب لكن جهود ترامب الاتجاه
المعاكس استمرت هذه القضيه في جورجيا سوف
تعزز القضيه الفيدراليه في يناور يناير
طبعا هذه قضيه مهمه هنا وهي ان هذه قضيه
فيدراليه للولايات المتحده وليس على مستوى
ولايه وهي تعني انه اذا ما اصبح رئيسا مره
اخرى لنستطيع ان يصدر عفوا بحق نفسه من
تبعتها وما الذي تضيفه هذه القضيه على ملف
ملاحقته قضائيا بشكل عام
هناك عنصران هنا يضيفان جديدا اولا هناك
جهود متساويقه اكثر تحاول اظهار ان تزييفا
للانتخابات وللنتائج وكيف انها حاولت
تزييف نتائج التصويت ورفعها
الكونغرس ايضا تشير الى جهود الرئيس ترامب
لتنزيف الانتخابات يا ادله دامغه هذه
المره طبعا كان هناك تسجيل صوتي في اكثر
من مناسبه يخاطب فيها امين سر الولايه
قائلا بانك ستقع في مشكله وتتهم بجريمه ان
لم تعثر لي على احد عشر الف صوت اذا سيكون
اصعب هذه المره
لوصف جريمه محاوله تزييف نتائج الانتخابات
فاكثر من المرات السابقه المرات السابقه
لم تكن قضيه بهذا الموضوع شكرا لك
المستشار بروسفاين في واشنطن
قال مكتب رئيس الحكومه الاسرائيليه
بنيامين نتنياهو ان اجتماعا ضمنتنياهو
وقيادات عسكريه تم الاتفاق خلاله على
ضروره ترك الخلافات السياسيه خارج الجيش
الاسرائيلي تفاصيل الخلافه السياسي في
اسرائيل على خلفيه التغييرات القضائيه
نتابعها في هذا التقرير
اتهامات جديده تواجه رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو يرى زعيم
المعارضه يائرلابيد ان ادعاء نتنياهو
اصدار تعليمات لرئيس الاركان بالحفاظ على
كفاءه واستعداد الجيش الاسرائيلي ليست سوى
محاوله مخزيه وجبنه للتهرب من المسؤوليه
حسب تعبيره هجوم لابيت تزامن مع الالغاء
نتنياهو عطله مخططه له في الجولان المحتل
ودعوته الاجتماع وزير الدفاع
وقياده الجيش الاسرائيلي لقاء قال عنه
مكتب نتنياهو انه روتيني وان جميع
المشاركين في المحادثات اتفقوا على ضروره
ترك الخلافه السياسيه خارج الجيش
الاسرائيلي الجدل المستمر ياتي على خلفيه
رفض جنود وضباط بينهم طيارون الالتحاق
بالتجنيد الطوعي على خلفيه التغييرات
القضائيه ولا تزال النسبه منخفضه جدا لكن
لحراكها رمزيه كبرى تنقسم هيكليه الجيش
الاسرائيلي الى الجيش النظامي وقوات
الاحتياط والقوات الخاصه وتعد قوات
الاحتياط في الجيش العمود الفقري في اوقات
الطوارئ التي تعيش اسرائيل في ظلها غالبيه
الوقت ويناط بها تنفيذ مختلف المهام
الامنيه والعسكريه ويتكون الاحتياط من
الجنود الذين ادوا الخدمه العسكريه
الاجباريه لمن يبلغون السن القانونيه ويتم
استدعائهم سنويا لدورات تدريبيه وبعد
الانتهاء من الخدمه الالزاميه يتحول
الجنود تلقائيا الى قوات الاحتياط وهي
تشكل غالبيه تعداد القوات المسلحه
تاخذنا فقره المتابعه الى السودان تحديدا
دارفور حيث تتواصل الاشتباكات في ولايه
جنوب دارفور منذ يومين تسلط الضوء على هذا
الاقليم المهم يقع اقليم دارفور في غرب
السودان تبلغ مساحته نحو 500 الف كيلو متر
مربع مما يجعله يمثل نحو ربع مساحه البلاد
يعتبر اي توتر في الاقليم لطبيعه حساسه
نظرا لموقعه الجغرافي ومجاورته لاربع دول
حيث تحده ليبيا من الشمال تشاد من الغرب
وافريقيا الوسطى من الجنوب الغربي اضافه
الى جنوب السودان يبلغ عدد سكان دارفور
نحو ثمانيه ملايين نسمه ويعتبر من
الاقاليم ذات التركيبه السكانيه المتنوعه
حيث تسكنه قبائل مستقره في المناطق
الريفيه واخرى بدويه راحله لانتجاع
المرحله هذه العوامل كلها جعلت اقليم
دارفور من اكثر المناطق السودانيه تضررا
من الحرب الدائره التي فقط في الخرطوم او
وسط ابريل نيسان الماضي فدارفور من اكثر
المناطق المرشحه لتصبح بؤره الصراع بعد
العاصمه الخرطوم بسبب تركيبتها القبليه
وتاريخها الطويل من الصراع وقد ذكرت الامم
المتحده ان 170 الفا نزحوا من بروني وحدها
وان 60% من سكان الاقليم مهددون بالمجاعه
بسبب الصراع الدائر وحذرت منظمه العفو
الدوريه من ان المدنيين يقتلون في منازلهم
اثناء بحثهم اليائس عن الطعام والماء
والدواء كما حذرت الامم المتحده من وقوع
تطهير عرقي في بعض مناطق الاقليم خاصه في
الجنينه ومستيري وكانت الامم المتحده قد
نشرت صورا جويه من وكاله ناسا تظهر وقوع
حرائق كبيره في مناطق ماهوله طيله الشهرين
الماضيين انضم الي هنا في الاستوديو
الدكتور اسامه عيدروس الاكاديمي السوداني
مخصص في شؤون السياسيه والعسكريه دكتور
مرحبا بك يا مرحبا هل
دارفور هي ارض المعركه والصراع المقبله
بعد العاصمه الخرطوم الناظر لدارفور اقليم
متوتر منذ منتصف السبعين صحيح يعني منذ ان
بدات الحرب الليبيه التشاديه في عهد
الزعيم الراحل معمر القذافي الرئيس الليبي
السابق
التوتر الاقليم ودخل السلاح بقوه وظل
الاقليم متوتر طوال هذه السنوات وخصوصا مع
ظهور العوامل الطبيعيه مثل المجاعات بسبب
التصحر والجفاف وغيرها منذ ان بدات هذه
الحرب
يعني هذه الحرب غريبه على دارفور غريبه
على دارفور باعتبار انه الدعم السريع من
مكون مجتمعي ظل في دارفور دوما يحظى بسند
الحكومه المركزيه وظل يقاتل يعني كل
الحركات ابناء هذه المنطقه ايوه نعم من
ابناء منطقه دارفور ظل يقاتل الحركات
المسلحه في دارفور بسند وغطاء من القوات
المسلحه اذا كان سند استخباري اذا كان سند
بالمدرعات والاسلحه الثقيله اذا كان سند
بالطيران الى ان يعني استمرت ازمه دارفور
لفتره طويله وتم حظر الطيران فوق دارفور
فالان هذه الحرب غريبه على دارفور باعتبار
انه هذا المكون نفسه هو الذي يشن الحرب
على الجيش وعلى الحكومه المركزيه لكن
الغرابه ايضا تاتي انه حرب الدعم السريع
استراتيجيا هي حرب الخرطوم النجاح
الاستراتيجي الذي حقه الدعم السريع انه
نقل الحرب الى العاصمه الى الخرطوم في
العمق الاستراتيجي للدوله لكن جيشه في
دارفور الان الدوله تحيل هذا الصراع الى
الى هل هذه الصوره واقعيه الذي حدث انه
يعني حينما حصلت الصدمه في الخرطوم هدات
الحرب في دارفور لانه المكونات المجتمعيه
كلها اجتمعت بما في ذلك الحركات المسلحه
التي وقعت اتفاقيات سلام جبى كلها جلست
واوقفت الصراع في دارفور الى حين لكن
استمرار الحرب في الخرطوم وقيام الدوله
المركزيه سبب ازمه انه قوات الدعم السريع
بعيده عن قيادتها بعيده عن اي ترتيبات
اداريه فبدات يعني غابه المرتبات بهذه
الحرب فبدات في اعمال نهب للاسواق في
الفاشر في الجنينه خطوره ان يتحول هذه
المنطقه ساحه فعليه للصراع ما الذي تشكله
على السودان وعلى دول الجوار هو بالضبط
يعني هذه منطقه كلها منطقه الصراع منطقه
صراع اقليمي صعب
جدا الان في النيجر الى درجه انه المنظمه
الاقليميه لم تستطع وجدت انها ستخوض حرب
بالوكاله في النيجر عن استراع الدول
العظمى
فابعدت نفسها ولم تستطيع التدخل في النيجر
ما يحدث في دارفور ايضا في طرف ثالث هو
الذي يطيل هذا الصراع اذا كان في الخرطوم
او في دارفور هذا الطرف يغذي هذا الصراع
بالاسلحه
بحشد المقاتلين من خارج الحدود يخلق توتر
كبير جدا في في هذه المنطقه وهذا الذي
اطال الصلاح خطوره الصراع انه حتى
المكونات القبليه يعني التي المتجانسه
الان بدات في صراع يعني فيما بينها حرب
دروس ما بين بني هلبا والسلامات وهي قبائل
تحسب من القبائل العربيه هذا النظام
النزاع الان مستمر
وقتل في اكثر من 180
شخص حتى الان وما زال مستمرا هو في جانب
اضعف الدعم السريع لحربه لانه مساحات
واسعه مثل المدينه نفسها تحررت الدعم
السريع في معظم هذه المدن في دارفور لا
يهاجم حاميات الجيش في الجنينه لم يهاجم
حاميات الجيش هاجم المدينه نفسها وارتكب
الفضائع والجرائم وفي سربا كذلك والان في
نيال اليوم هو يهجم على احياء المواطنين
ويمارس السلب والنقل لكن ضعف بسبب
الصراعات الدائره امام هذا الواقع احتواء
التوتر ممكنا لا زلت ممكنه في دارفور في
كل السودان ممكنه اذا توقفت اولا الاطراف
الخارجيه واذا توقفت حرب الخرطوم يمكن
احتواء الحرف لماذا لان المكونات الاهليه
المجتمعيه ما زال فيها الحكمه منذ التفجر
الصراع في 15 ابريل كثير من الادارات
الاهليه نا ئت بنفسها عن الصراع وابتعدت
عنه واعلن الصراحه انها ليست خلف الدعم
السريع في حربه هذه الحكمه هي التي يمكن
ان تجنب اقليم دارفور الحرب القادمه
الدكتور اسامه عيدروس شكرا لك شكرا جزيلا
يقول العلماء ان التغير المناخي يجعل
الامطار الموسميه اكثر غزاره وتقلبا بينما
باتت الفيضانات اكثر حده في الصين مثلا
ارتفعت حصيله ضحايا انزلاق التربه شماليه
البلاد الى واحد وعشرين قتيلا وشهدت الصين
فيضانات ومعدلات امطار غير مسبوقه في
الاسابيع الاخيره في اعقاب موجه حر
تاريخيه في بنغلاديش قتل 55 شخصا على
الاقل جراء امطار غزيره وانزلاقات للتربه
تضرب مناطق عده منذ اسبوعين وطالت اثارها
اكثر من مليون شخص في ميانمار تسببت
فيضانات وسيول ناجمه عن امطار موسميه في
مقتل خمسه اشخاص وارغمت السلطات على اجلاء
نحو 50 الف شخص في اليابان دعت السلطات
السكانه للاستعداد لاعصار قوي يتقدم ببطء
ويتوقع ان يضرب البلاد خلال اسبوع عطلات
صيفيه هو مشهد مناخي مضطرب حذرت منه
تقارير كثيره في السنوات الماضيه والامل
كل الامل ان ينتبه الجميع من حكومات
ومنظمات وشركات وافراد الى وضع الخطط
المناسبه تحسبا لما هو انت شكرا للمتابعه
الى اللقاء بامان الله ورعايته